PROFESSOR: The left hand side
here is 0 because H0 and N0
by taking the
eigenstate equation is
equal to En0 times N0.
So this really evaluates to En0
and therefore the two cancel,
so this thing is 0.
The right hand side,
this is a number, En1.
It's a number.
It's in an expectation value.
N0 has a unit expectation
value, so this is En1.
That's the number.
And then I have
an operator here.
So this is minus N0 delta H N0.
So we get a very famous
and important equation
that En1 is equal
to N0 delta H N0.
The first correction
to the energy
is obtained by finding
the expectation
value of the perturbation
in the unperturbed state.
So you should be
happy to hear that.
It says that to find the first
correction in the energy,
you don't need to know
what happens to the state.
I didn't need to know what N1
was, how the state changes,
to know how the energy changes.
The energy changed before,
and I just don't need it.
I just need the original
state and the perturbation.
So it's a very nice result, and
it has a simple generalization.
The simple generalization
is that I'm
going to use another blackboard,
but let's look at it.
The simple generalization comes
from doing the same exact thing
with the order k equation.
So let's do that.
I put an N0 to the
left of this equation.
Now what do we get?
From this term, we get
0 for the same reason.
There's an N0 now
here, and the H0
is killed by this
term, gives you 0.
And then we're going
to continue with this
and see what happens
with this various terms.
Let's look at it.
So I'll put the N0--
0 on the left hand
side was equal to 0.
And on the right hand
side, what do we get?
Well, let me do a
couple of terms.
N0 En1 minus delta H and k minus
1 plus all these other terms.
So look what happens here.
Let's do the next
term, for example.
En2, N0, and k minus 2.
Well, from here,
this is a number,
so I have here this goes out the
overlap of N0 with nk minus 1.
But we said that all
the higher corrections
have no component along N0.
So this thing will give you 0.
On the other hand,
here is an operator,
so there's nothing I can say.
So I'll write it minus
N0 delta H and k minus 1.
And then what else?
Well, you have N0
then k minus 2 here.
That's 0 because this
is a higher state
and all the terms give you
0 until you get here where
the N0 with the N0 give you 1.
So the only term that
survives is the last one,
and we get enk.
So this gives you
the result that enk
is equal to N0 delta
H and k minus 1.
I box it because it's
another nice formula.
It tells you that
the kth order energy
is given if you know
the k minus 1 state.
If you have figured out
the k minus 1 correction
to the state, then you know the
energy of the kth correction.
This formula
certainly works when
k is equal to 1 in which case
it reproduces the formula we had
on the blackboard to the right.
When k is equal to 1, you
get the expectation value
of delta H around zero.